what's your favorite element what's your
least favorite element hi what's the
most dangerous element I think my most
my favorite element is probably sodium
because if you watch the videos you'll
see that na na was my the nickname that
my mother used and what my children
called their grandmother and so I think
that it still gives me a warm feeling
I'm not sure that I have a least
favorite element because they're just
sudden that I don't think about very
often and I suppose really that the
elements which don't have a proper name
now like 113 onwards I'm not very fond
of though I am quite fond of element 117
because nobody's ever discovered it but
thousands of people have watched the
video about it and as for the most
dangerous I suppose the most dangerous
element would be cesium because it
reacts so explosively or perhaps
fluorine because it will attack nearly
all the other elements but somehow
because my colleague describes potassium
is evil
I've always been most frightened of
potassium yeah
how did you get the idea to start the
periodic table of videos how did you
meet Brady I met Brady because he was
making videos about science in
Nottingham and I'd never thought of
making a video for youtube
while making video about anything and he
came and videoed me and we really got on
well together and started talking and
Brady said I can't remember whether it
was then or a few days later that he'd
really like to make a video about the
periodic table he thought it could be
done I was not sure I just didn't
believe that you could say enough about
some of these elements but where then we
started making these videos and I think
really it was only after we'd started
that we began to understand how we could
actually make some of these videos and I
think the most important thing about
these videos is that we have lots of
different people doing it and none of us
know what the other ones are saying so I
have no idea what Pete or Debbie or
Steve is doing and they don't know what
I'm saying and that's what makes it such
fun so when they appear on YouTube it's
the first time I've seen them and the
first time the others have as well so I
almost enjoyed as much as you'd I hope
you do what kind of dad do you have so I
don't have a dog at all many years ago
my family had a an English dog called
the border terrier the border is the
border between England and Scotland
which is quite a small dog but very
intelligent but I have dog toys but no
dog
I have hang on little bit worried about
dog toys
the reason I have dog toys is because my
son had the ped toad who still lives in
the other room we might be able to see
him and I have to go to the pet shop
each week to buy food for him and when I
don't even know to him but for it and
when I go I often buy dog toys the
couple here they bought today
and these are molecules of c60 or could
be something else
why is liquid oxygen magnetic but not
oxygen all oxygen is magnetic the gas
the liquid and the solid but the reason
why liquid oxygen is much more magnetic
than the gas is that the molecules are
much closer together in the liquid so in
the gas the molecules a long way away
and the magnetic effect depends on how
many molecules you've got in your flask
or your test tube so if you have a
liquid they're all very close together
so you get much bigger effect when
they're far apart in the gas why don't
you ever talk about the Hindenburg in
your hydrogen video because it'd be cool
to hear your perspective oh look at that
and you've drawn the Hindenburg have you
the reason that I don't talk about the
Hindenburg the Hindenburg was an airship
that a German airship that blew up I
think it was in 1936 or 1937 as it was
docking near New York was actually New
Jersey New Jersey well you know to
foreigners it's all much the same so in
New Jersey adjusted it attached up onto
the mooring post he burst into flames
and the cause of the immediate cause was
believed to be a spark because it was
earth than this cause the spark the
argument is whether it was the hydrogen
that initially caught fire or the skin
of the actual airship the airship was
enormous Lee long and it was made at a
very light aluminium frame that was
covered with sunlight material rather
like canvas which was then painted
silver and inside were a whole number of
balloons of hydrogen what is believed
have happened is that actually the
initial cause of the fire was the paint
on the cloth and the hydrogen only
started burning later and then the
aluminium or some of the aluminium
caught fire some melted aluminium has
quite a low melting point it melts round
about 500 degrees centigrade we've even
had aluminium melting in our lab so the
reason I didn't talk about it is not
sure that hydrogen was the really the
cause of the explosion the Challenger
Space Shuttle when that blew up in the
1980s that really was an explosion of
hydrogen because the one of the Rockets
the booster rockets that was on the side
of the tank of liquid hydrogen the
tankers the big fat tank in the middle
one of these Rockets developed a leak
and burnt a hole into the side of the
liquid oxygen and liquid hydrogen tanks
and that is what exploded so it is
really I should have been talking about
the smell Challenger Space Shuttle
rather than the Hindenburg but on the
other hand most people associate the
Hindenburg with hydrogen well I think
what is sad about the Hindenburg is
because the Hindenburg was used as a
political symbol by Nazi Germany that
America that had helium which doesn't
burn which could have been used in the
Hindenburg refused the supply Germany
with helium because it was being used
for political purposes so I think the
lesson of the Hindenburg tragedy is that
if people learn to collaborate and live
together in political harmony some of
these accidents would not take place
when did you start your water bottle
collection on may we donate some water
bottles for your collection he'll be
very excited about that
there you go well first of all thank you
very much for the water bottles I don't
have any like these in my collection I
started my water bottle collection in
I think 2001 that's eight years ago I
was at a conference in China and I was
ill and I was sitting in my hotel room
thinking about my next lecture that I
had to give him the next conference
which was about the plastic that's in
bottles and I thought it'd be quite nice
to have a photograph with three or four
bottles from different countries so I
brought one back from China and I had
found some that I'd not thrown away from
other places and so I showed this slide
at the next conference and I said this
is my part of my collection of water
bottles from around the world and then I
thought after the lecture will I better
have a bit of a collection in case
somebody wants to see them and so it is
just snowball and now the shelf has
collapsed in my office because there are
so many bottles and these are great so
thank you very much I shall remember
these is coming from your class right